bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fari j
oggi siamo sues lander di harry vol
l'abbiamo aspettato per mesi e
finalmente uscito per chi non lo
conoscesse lander di arrivo sarebbe il
sequel del primo slider quello dove
c'era il mega dildo vabbè primo slam del
comunque quello che ha fatto successo di
aids babes da quello slider lì poi sono
usciti un casino di altri slider fatti
da altri autori che copiavano diciamo il
primo questo è l'unico slider uscito
fatto dallo stesso autore dopo il
primissimo slider comunque iniziamo a
stage selection è occupato perché
ovviamente ci saranno più mappe per ora
ce n'è solo uno essendo una beta
ovviamente quindi andiamo su start game
ok ragazzi amo partiti non so dove sono
come al solito c'è una casetta oxide
park estri canoa
ok ho preso l'insegna doveva la metto
nelle mutande
va beh intanto la telecamera è partita e
siamo già cinque minuti di video scritto
in alto a destra anche se ho appena
iniziato a ben si vede che s'è fatto un
giretto prima hawks hyde park
ok anche questo posso prendersi tutte le
mutande in tema ha detto dettori o skype
box nelle mutande icann bwin
niente raganelli nei giochi oro non si
può leggere un cazzo che sparisce tutto
subito oxide park anche questo posso
prendere si infila tutto lì
va bene la casetta l'abbiamo
praticamente depredata e vabbè c'è anche
la finestrella qui vabbè andiamo avanti
e non perdiamoci nei dettagli nuotate
che comunque l'interfaccia è composta
dalla bella batteria in alto a sinistra
che già mezza scarica lo zoom molto
pixelloso e vabbè in alto c'è scritto
recco i minuti di registrazione anche se
siamo appena partiti sta già cinque
minuti si vede che si è fatto cinque
minuti di camminata eh vabbè comunque a
parte questo la vedo già qualcosa una
torre o un faro per non perdersi
ovviamente nel mezzo alla radura da c'è
qualcos'altro
posso tipo si possa indirizzare meglio
la luce per vedere nei posti più lontani
la c'è un cesso
e vabbè poi ci andiamo c'è stato anche
sembra vagamente una torre dell'acqua
con una scala possa salire
no c'è qualcosa qui ok prima pagina
prima pagina don't look
ho sentito dei passi
ho sentito dei passi provenire dalla giu
li ho sentiti non sono pazzo
cioè si sono pazzo ma li ho sentiti
comunque va beh dicevo
il mini cosa stavo dicendo sistos lander
ci sono le stesse pagine del primo
slider appunto perché è stato fatto
dagli stessi autori e quindi le pagine
sono le stesse
ovviamente però il gioco è tutto diverso
come potete vedere è realistico in una
maniera incredibile finora e lo slider
più reale ovvero la colla grafica e
tutto il resto è realistico al massimo
c'è il cesso pubblico c'è un bengala
acceso probabilmente passato di qua alan
wake
c'è un'altra pagina che entrano e sono
già due ragazzi posso entrare a fare i
miei bisogni no vero e vabbè andiamo per
il sentiero sono già due pagine abbiamo
appena iniziato ho avuto un culo che la
metà basta credo perché minchia due
pagine appena partiti è già tanto
considerando che non ho la più pallida
idea di dove sto andando e c'è vedo dei
container vedo dei container kullman se
va bene non frega niente di cosa c'è
scritto basta che trova le pagine
barili ancora si maestro posto è
impossibile trovarla pagina questo
ovunque vabbè lasciamo perche questo
successo
c'è una semi interferenza che non
capisco da dove proviene però non c'è lo
senta c'è la pagina però e sono a tre
sono a 3 fuck yeah sono altre pagine tre
pagine senza lo slider vedo vedo c'è
qualcosa li vedo già qualcosa laggiù
cioè pieroni robins lander raga dovunque
guardi c'è qualcosa quindi le pagine c'è
possono essere localizzate in varie zone
c'è una macchina e c'è la quarta pagina
non trovate già 4 cazzo cazzo no no no
no no no no no ok ok no il pedofilo è
tornato raga il pedofilo è tornato merda
stasera c'erano anche le iene in tv
perché sto giocando sta roba
non lo vedo più ma non importa cos'è
questa è una canoa
cosa ci fa una canon arriva cinque
pagine cinque pagine appena iniziato
raga non ci credo allora fermi un attimo
sta succedendo di tutto sto trovando
tutte le pagine a caso perché la zona è
anche abbastanza grossa tipo quella this
land and round quindi enorme e ho già
trovato cinque fasce e cioè non me lo
spiego come ho fatto avere tutto sto
culo nasce qualcosa sì
bene ok quello è un punto di risparmi sa
che non ci posso andare credo si vabbè è
praticamente vi spiego in sos lander non
si parte sempre nella stessa zona ma
quando si avvia la partita si può
partire in tre zone diverse questa è
un'altra delle tre
noi siamo partiti nella prima che è che
quella che avete visto e poi sono ancora
un'altra che dopo non so se ci andiamo
ma spero di riuscire a trovare pagine
prima dato che sono già 5 non mi spiego
come ho fatto
qua c'è un cartelloni tanto c'è lo slang
disegnato fantastico
e c'è anche la sesta pagina linea l'on
un cazzo porca [ __ ] ma che cazzo ok
ok
raga stavo trovando le pagine con una
velocità assurda ma evidentemente lo
slider man in questo slider è talmente
spaventoso che non riesci a muoverti
quando lo vedi
riproviamo faccio un altro tentativo non
ha veramente è stato un qualcosa di
assurdo
siamo partiti di nuovo dovevamo prima
tra i 3 span sono ripartito di qua
credo sia lo stesso posto di prima no
vabbè raga ma è stato assurdo c'è lo
slider ti compare in una maniera
incredibile non è più non è più il fatto
che se ti giri te lo trovi dietro 4 puoi
trovare proprio davanti mentre anche se
lo fai così e non te ne accorgi c'è
veramente assurdo dell'aga non lo so
perché sinceramente non me l'aspettavo
di tor allo slider e cos'è una tenda si
fa il campeggiatore a tempo libero rose
lander mi fa piacere
beh c'è anche il fuoco acceso e c'è la
prima pagina follows vabbè comunque la
zona è veramente enorme oltre al fatto
che ci saranno un casino di pagine è
veramente assurdo ma no veramente
veramente raga mi ha scioccato sto fatto
perché non me l'aspettavo
non mi aspettavo che lo svenderà
arrivasse così all'improvviso c'è io io
sono abituato al fatto che se mi giro mi
trovo lander dietro ma intanto la c'è
qualcosa che non ho visto però vabbè
aspettate un attimo che la ho visto pare
che c'era era il punto di prima dove
c'era la pagina comunque ricapitolando
ero arrivato
maliseti perché voi sti passi ogni tanto
c'è io sento sento dei passi strani ogni
tanto sento come se non me lo so
spiegare neanch'io comunque c'è un cesso
è il cesso di prima si vabbè comunque è
leggermente alto anche lo slang in
questo slider qua non c'è la pagina
mentre prima c'era ok perfetto
evidentemente non c'è dato che ci sono
tanti posti dove metterle non le mettono
ovunque ed è giusto sa cosa è veramente
stupendo ragazzo slider a parte il fatto
che ho già perso qualche anno di vita ma
pazienza tanto ormai morirò giovane
perché tra tutti gli anni di vita che ho
perso con i videogiochi horror che ho
fatto ho perso il conto ci sono di nuovo
i container spero di ritrovarla pagina
anche perché potrebbe essere ovunque
dato che si spostano ogni volta che che
restarti una mappa si spostano invece
l'ho trovata subito che culo league mia
l'on
va bene due su otto raga spero veramente
di non in controllo ancora raga perché
devo riprendermi da prima
c'è di nuovo il cartellone perfetto e la
canoa dovrebbe essere anche nei dintorni
io veramente mi tufferò e volentieri
però va beh neanche asi invece c'è la
pagina no no no no no no no no no è no
no no no no un cazzo lo dico io no no no
cos'è c'è l'interferenza ma non ce lo
slider cell interferenza ma non c'è lo
slider credo non lo vedono non c'è
perfetto allora andiamo a cene via
perché non vorrei mai che spuntasse come
prima ok
stiamo andando non so dove dovrei
tornare dove la prima perché avevo visto
un edificio
ok un'altra pagina perfetto siamo a tre
ok
ho visto qualcosa di in alto qualcosa di
rosso prima non ho capito bene neanche
lo aspettate un attimo c'è qualcosa tipo
di di rosso che cazzo è un faro c'è un
faro laggiù posso andarci non lo so se
ci possa andare ma spero di che cazzo è
mai un palo della luce mi chiamo scambi
non scambiamo perloz lander un cazzo
ok ok questo non è un palo della luce
corri corri corri corri corri ok ok ok
ok veri è ok
mi avvicino alla macchina io fossi lui
la prenderei anche visto che accesa ma
non fa niente
e dov'è eccolo il pedofilo non si vede
bene perché l'interferenza non ti fa
vedere proprio una ceppa però
evidentemente raga anche in questo
slider il pedofilo è pericoloso dicevo
comunque il fatto che ti appare così è
veramente pesante perché non te lo
aspetteresti mai
va beh noi andiamo io voglio tornare
davvero prima perché ho visto un
edificio ha chiuso magari è più sicuro o
magari no però vale la pena tentare
ok cos'è sta roba siamo che cazzo di
posto è questo siamo in
non so spiegare comunque va beh non ci
sono pagine credo no perfetto devo devo
assolutamente ritrovare il punto dove
dove c'è stata un'interferenza ok c'è
l'interferenza cell interferenza non so
dove posso
merda ok raga è impossibile è
impossibile non te ne accorgi quando
quando ti è vicino non te ne accorgi
proprio cioè come se non ci fosse c'è
tipo adesso non c'è mi giro così e c'è
certo non te ne accorgi anche se non c'è
bisogno di girarsi proprio te lo trovi
davanti così senza motivo io non so
neanche che cosa servono sui cartelloni
ma li prendo lo stesso
vabbè come potete notare comunque siamo
partiti in una zona diversa
stavolta siamo al al porto credo sia un
porto qualcosa del genere
faccio l'ultimo tentativo perché se no
vado avanti troppo nel caso non riesca a
finirlo ma qui c'è un cesso prima ma non
c'era la canoa qua a ma si vede che
cambiano anche la posizione degli
oggetti non solo dei delle pagine che
tra l'altro non c'è neanche qui a se
invece c'è mi ripeto se non riesca a
finirlo farò magari un altro episodio
nel quale spero di riuscire a finirlo
e vabbè io voglio assolutamente trovare
l'edificio perché è il posto dove
praticamente ancora non sono andato
questo va bè sempre al centro anche
perché non è che possono spostarlo più
di tanto visto che enorme seconda pagina
perfetto ok sono salito sulla collina
raga perché ancora non c ero salito e
vedo qualcos'altro lì un altro bengala
alla canoa
allora adesso voi mi spiegate che cazzo
ci fa una canoa in mezzo al bosco c'è ma
ma che cazzo ci fa una canoa in mezzo al
bosco non ha senso cioè mi va bene che
spostino e gli oggetti ma perché la
canoa deve essere in mezzo al bosco c'è
appaga jato un po troppo diciamo però
vabbè
si vede che non si era accorto di
arrivare di essere arrivato arriva
perfetto qua c'è la torre dell'acqua che
comunque diversa da quella che avevo
visto all'inizio quella dove abbiamo
visto all'inizio ci aveva anche la scala
e sono tre
ok perfetto mancano tutte le altre ma
vabbè non importa io cos'è sta roba
hanno semplicemente la mia cazzo dove
dove non lo vedo non lo vedono lo vedo
ma mismi mi muovo mi muovo perché lei
non voglio trovarmi davanti
ok perfetto qua c'è la quarta la iv la
terza un amico lo porta pagina perfetto
ok ce la posso fare sì ce la posso fare
un cazzo però vabbè l'importante è
crederci ci credo ce la posso fare anche
se probabilmente morirò adesso ma non
importa da quella pagina non c'è ma vedo
interferenze
vedi interferenze a caso non c'è lo
slider raga ma continua ad esserci
interferenza porca [ __ ] cielo svendere
mica quanto è alto guardate quanto è
alto madonna è una roba enorme via vico
via merda cos'è
qui si sta avvicinando oppure
semplicemente interferenze a caso
non voglio scoprirlo vai vai vai bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye merda c'è
qualcos'altro raggiunsi c'è
qualcos'altro
cos'è e l'edificio l'edificio merda
merda merda no no no no entra dentro
entro 30 entra entra entra
entra cazzo ok ok ok calmi calmi
calmissimi c'è una vasca da bagno
perfetto allora proseguiamo di qua
speriamo di non incontrare nessuno
vabbè c'è cosa sono lavandini cessi
perfetto bello il su dificio bene siamo
stati dentro siamo forse al sicuro spero
di sì vabbè armadietti ok perfetto
possiamo tranquillizzarci un attimo
valigette perfetto piene di soldi perché
lo svenderà anche fa affari loschi c'è
un piatto e un microonde se sapevo
portava anche i sandwich pazienza sarà
pro prossima volta una piantina e vabbè
tranquilli tranquilli perfetto ok vado
di qua qua ci sono già stato perfetto
vai
ma cos'è cos'è ci sono ci sono le pagine
disegnate sul muro però c'è a ecco la
pagina perfetto 55 su otto stiamo stiamo
giungendo alla fine se riesco non lo so
va bene ok per ora sono stato abbastanza
tranquillo c'è ma qui dentro intendo
perfetto c'è vedo anche qualcos'altro
sono caduto
ok c'è no non lo so se c'è la pagina
però già si quando già presa mi pare e
vabbè sento dei passi merda sento dei
pali dove merda merda no non mi prendere
non mi prenderò i stronzo non mi
prenderei sono troppo vicino per morire
sono troppo vicino alla fine primo
tentativo veramente siamo al terzo non
importa se c'è un'altra pagina ragazza i
suoi 8 non ci posso credere
sei sotto sono di nuovo vicino alla fine
prima ero morto al 6 si spengono miss
punti come prima perché sarebbe tragico
quello già merda dove no no no no no no
no no no no no riuscirà a raggiungere
qualcosa 12 devo riuscire a trovare
pagine riuscì a trovare facile 903 77
non ci credo 7 ma rimane una ragazza
rimane una rimane una 2 dove come faccio
a trovare l'ultima pagina raga
impossibile
vabbè dove
no
aiuto
la chiesa merda cielo quasi c'ero quasi
riuscito porca vacca ma non fa niente
dai per oggi la chiudo qui perché la mia
voce sta chiedendo veramente pietà è
stato un trauma stasera non dormo merda
eh va beh
fatemi sapere se vi piace perché se vi
piace proverà a finirlo nel prossimo
episodio
io per ora mi ritiro perché veramente
devo riuscire in qualche modo a trovare
qualche sonnifero per casa perché se non
stasera veramente non dormo se vi è
piaciuto il video come al solito
lasciate un commento è un mi piace anche
alla pagina facebook che trovate come
sempre nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo un prossimo video bella ragazzi